well how did you get started in
filmmaking I think I was born with a
camera in my hand I don't remember ever
not wanting to make movies but the thing
that was interesting was I was when I
was little I thought the actors kind of
made it up as I went along so I wanted
to be an actor and then as I got older
two things happened one I realized I
suck at acting ha ha but two I began to
learn oh there's a writer and a director
and as people behind the camera and to
me that became more interesting I rather
tell the story then you know then until
somebody else's story through my
performance whatever I just I found that
was much more where I was I was geared
to so when I was 11 I started directing
movies but when you were 10 I understand
something very fascinating when I was 10
I auditioned for for the law for the
lead role of Danny in the shining they
were casting out of Denver where I lived
because Kubrick you know the film takes
place in Denver but in Colorado better
cast at Denver so they kids could send
in headshots so it's in the headshot and
I got an audition so I met with Jenn
Harlan in a hotel and proceeded to bomb
an audition for Kubrick and I can
proudly say that I've been rejected by
Stanley Kubrick so didn't get rejected
get rejected by the best but that's yeah
that's what happened so going back to
that experience now that you cast people
does there anything that you take from
that or no that was just a 10 year old
going on a cool vacation with his
parents well no I think the the casting
for the shining of vacation it was just
literally down to like the hotel
downtown for the shining they were
casting kids who weren't necessarily
actors so there wasn't really like read
this page they I knew it was a horror
movie my mom knew Stephen King's work
and then she read the book because of
the because the audition was coming and
they knew who Kubrick was like oh this
is gonna be really spooky movie too high
news I didn't know the story exactly
that new is a haunted house thing and a
scary hotel and I was total scaredy-cat
as a kid always hiding under under the
covers from The Blob or whatever and I
was worried that if they knew I was
easily scared that they wouldn't cast me
because they wouldn't want to work with
somebody not realizing of course there's
a thousand people around in lights in
your face and thinking oh you should be
in a dark
room and I'm gonna get scared they're
not gonna want to work with somebody get
scared who can't just pretend to be
scared but it's actually scared so I
wasn't thinking of myself I'm not gonna
get scared matter what they do I'm not
gonna I'm gonna put on a brave face so
the guy started by asking me what scares
you trying to get a fear reaction out of
me because I'm a kid and I'm thinking
I'm not gonna get scared no matter what
nothing scares me nothing scares me
think oh come on what scared you well
maybe sudden movement and he kicks over
a chair and I don't jump but he goes
you're bullshitting me and I'm like no
no I mean I'm totally talked myself out
of a job
I just been the scared little kid that I
really was and I'm trying to act brave I
might have had a shot but no when I
audition actors I tend to work with
actors so I you know I don't need to
play tricks with them I just sit on the
sides and tell them the part and they
come in and they give me their take on
it so they act I don't know what I was
doing
you